my name is rich lesser I'm the chairman
of the boston consulting group BCG in
North and South America and today's
session that I moderated was on boosting
productivity through credit and we had a
terrific set of panelists that brought
many different perspectives from the
private sector from the public sector
and from from organizations that are
focused on improving competitiveness we
had a wide-ranging discussion the themes
that that really came through very
strongly were first that well the first
and obvious point is that improving
credit access is essential to driving
growth in the emerging markets and we
see that around the world and that's
true not just for very large
institutions but for very small
companies and entrepreneurs as well and
then the question is how to do that and
how to do that in ways that are really
lasting and we talked about several
different things the first of course is
an underpinning of trust its its
macroeconomic environments that foster a
willingness to invest a willingness to
save and a willingness to extend credit
so the strong macroeconomic environment
that's been created in Latin America in
recent years is essential but beyond the
trust at the at the level of the country
is what occurs at the level of the
individual business or a person and
there it's essential that trust needs to
have a foundation of transparency the
informal networks in informal companies
and individuals are very large in in
most latin american countries and if
we're really going to make progress we
need to have incentives for people to
want to register as individuals and as
businesses because it's only through the
availability of information that anyone
will be willing to extend credit
in a in a reasonably priced manner and
we also need to reduce the perceived
risks and burdens of registering which
means we need to bring down tax rates
you need to bring down the regulatory
burden that's often associated with that
so this theme of trust and transparency
is the first underlying element of being
able to boost credit in these markets
the second is creative private public
partnerships that that government and
banks and institutions need to work
together to create mechanisms to
encourage sharing to address regulatory
constraints that exist today and to
create environments that encourage
private institutions to rent but also
foster an environment of competition and
so that so that individuals wanting
credit have multiple sources to turn to
and the last we had a number of very
interesting innovative mechanisms that
have been tried whether was about
mortgages in Brazil weather was
mechanisms to have risk pooling because
anyone small business might be too risky
to extend credit but if there's a way to
pull it then an investor can invest with
with more diversification and a lower
overall risk and therefore be willing to
lend at a lower overall rate and we saw
a number of examples in Colombia and
Brazil in other places around the world
where innovative mechanisms have really
boosted credit and created new
opportunities so those were the key
themes of our panel was very interesting
and really gave a sense of optimism and
opportunity for the years ahead thank
you